Talk a lot about boundaries within relationships
on this app. And so
people find it very surprising when they realize that
I've only ever really had to walk away from a
very small number of relationships,
because I truly believe
boundaries help you maintain relationships,
not get rid of relationship.
When I have had to walk away from somebody
or relationship,
it is always been because I have seen
something in their character
or in their motivations
that is no longer compatible with
the type of relationship I can have.
It's not what they've done,
it's who they are.
Maybe there was an action or an incident
that was a catalyst for this discovery,
but the only time that I've actually had to walk
fully away from a relationship with somebody
is because I had realized that my happiness and health
is not compatible with the form of toxicity
that they bring to the table.
I wish you well.
I hope you have a great life,
but I'm not gonna be part of it.
I'm gonna be going that way,
and I've never regretted it.